partez pas en cours élevés pas les yeux
aussi à l'écouté mois puis après vous
déciderez vous voulez rester on va
parler de ménopause en juin 2021 l'auto
meinau un documentaire de véronique
cloutier fait sensation je sais c'est
pas sexy pantoute pourquoi parler de ça
parce que moi je savais rien là dessus
jusqu'à temps que ça me tombe d'en face
comme une brique et un fanal le
documentaire est touchant et sans pudeur
chaleur et somni démangeaisons
sécheresse vaginale perte de libido état
dépressif tout j'ai tout du loto mais
nous donne espoir si tu savais verrous
le tout ce que je traite simplement
qu'avec l'hormonothérapie saint croyable
les femmes qui prennent des hormones
aurait une meilleure qualité de vie
d'abord ça des femmes qui vont dormir
mieux qu'ils vont avoir une meilleure
concentration c'est des tanks souvent
vont dire je pète le feu
mais beaucoup de femmes ont peur de
l'hormonothérapie l'auto meinau explique
que certaines hormones sont plus
sécuritaires que d'autres la
démonstration est l'effet que les
hormones guigma tic sont supérieures
sont faits
on écoute suspendu toutes les femmes
devraient prendre des hormones et aucun
risque si on prend des hormones
bioéthique mais deux semaines plus tard
une série d'articles démoli en partie
l'auto meinau la réalité serait pas mal
moins sexy écrite en aucune société
savante n'a conclu à la supériorité de
l'hormonothérapie bio identique de plus
la docteur sylvie demers piliers de
l'argumentaire de l'auto meinau aurait
tendance à prendre certaines données et
on oublier d'autres avec la
confusion quand j'ai fermé ma voire de
tampon j'ai ouvert une boîte de pandore
c'est une quête très très personnel que
j'entreprends sous vos yeux c'est une
quête pour une enquête
une enquête c'était à nous d'en faire
une
pourquoi autant d'informations
contradictoires
faut-il prendre des hormones si oui
lesquels à notre tour nous avons ouvert
une boîte de pandore
[Musique]
le matin et moi je suis une typiquement
gens me lever à 4h30 et jusqu'à 7 heures
est désormais alors soit de l'écriture
de la lecture d'articles scientifiques
tous les jours je lis sur les humains
même un bac à rousset
la docteur sylvie demers est une
passionnée voire une obsédée des
hormones quand elle est devenue médecin
il ya 25 ans l'hormonothérapie avait le
vent dans les voiles tous pointent qu'à
dans la même direction c'est à dire que
les hormones féminines c'était ça
donnait une protection contre
l'ostéoporose contre les maladies
cardiovasculaires et beaucoup disaient
contre la maladie d'alzheimer aussi
qu'elle à peu près là je dirais le peu
près la moitié des femmes qui prenaient
c'était l'âge d'or des hormones un âge
d'or qui s'est terminée brusquement en
juillet 2002 une vaste étude américaine
conclut que les traitements hormonaux de
substitution pour les femmes ménopausées
présente plus de danger que de bienfaits
pour la santé
l'étude ouailles la women of energy tm
est la toute première étude clinique
randomisée contrôlée d'envergure sur
l'hormonothérapie elle crée une onde de
choc on a tellement donné dans mon aux
thérapies aux femmes alsa on va diminuer
la mortalité est malheureusement sans
nous montrer que c'était faux on vient
de mettre fin prématurément à l'étude
parce qu'on a observé que la prise
d'hormones augmente le risque de cancer
du sein de maladie cardiovasculaire et
d'avc c'est une panique du jour au
lendemain vraiment un os
ccsa tout changer les femmes jettent
leurs hormones aux poubelles oui j'ai
chaud mais bon j'aime mieux ne pas avoir
un cancer du sein les femmes étaient
apeurés on leur disait qu'elle devait
arrêter c'est tellement risqué
l'étude doit et à l'effet d'une bombe
parce qu'elle est largué tout travers
dans la population
l'utilisation combinée d'oestrogène et
de progestérone
accroît les risques de cancer du sein de
24% et des risques de crise cardiaque
augmente de l'ordre de 29 % les médias
reprennent les chiffres lancés en
conférence de presse par le directeur de
l'étude des pourcentages qui font
paraître les risques beaucoup plus
effrayant qu'ils ne le sont il y avait
une hausse des cotes cancer du sein qui
arrivait à la limite de la
significativité c'était points 8 code
plus pour 1000 femmes par an en termes
absolus c'est très très très peu le
risque augmente et de cancer du sein de
26% voulait dire que chaque année sur
1000 femmes qui prennent des hormones
3,8 vont développer un cancer du sein
contre 3 chez celles qui n'en prennent
pas c'est quand on pense cancer du sein
que c'est quand même une femme sur neuf
dans leur vie puis l'on arrive un risque
de moins de un sur mille
le risque est tellement mince qu'il
n'est pas qualifié de significatif par
les chercheurs mais ce n'est pas ce que
les médias retière
dire en manchette que la combinaison
d'oestrogène et de progestérone
augmenter le risque de cancer du sein
était trompeur voire malhonnête
selon le docteur havre home looming un
hématologue américain spécialiste de la
ménopause long de choc qui a suivi la
divulgation des résultats a été provoqué
volontairement
le directeur de l'étude le docteur
jacques loiseau à 10 ans voulait stopper
le train de l'hormonothérapie et le
faire avec le plus de publicité possible
dans un texte publié en 1996 le
directeur explique que les hormones sont
de plus en plus prescrite pour des
indications qui ne sont pas suffisamment
documenté comme les problèmes cardiaques
ou un taux élevé de cholestérol et une
folle il pensait que les hormones
étaient utilisés de façon inappropriée
et il était en croisade pour arrêter
cela
les pourcentages de risques alarmants
sont diffusées une semaine avant la
publication de l'article scientifique
qui les met en contexte
ce n'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
normalement d'habitude l'article
scientifique et publié en premier et les
médecins ont le temps de le lire et de
se forger une opinion et après seulement
la nouvelle se rend au patient doit
quand les patientes débarque inquiète
chez leur médecin beaucoup d'entre eux
n'ont pas encore compris que lis tu dois
et comporte une faille majeure
les participantes était trop vieille et
moche women la plupart des femmes
atteignent la ménopause entre 45 et 51
hommes et l'âge moyen des participantes
était de 63 ans ou 6 6 3
les participantes étaient déjà
fragilisées par le vieillissement
quand on vieillit nos vaisseaux sanguins
rétrécissent laisse trop jeune peut
entraîner une agglutination des
plaquettes
l'augmentation de 29 % du risque de
maladies cardiovasculaires était due en
grande partie à l'âge des participantes
une réanalyse des résultats publiés en
2007 a d'ailleurs révélé que chez les
femmes ménopausées depuis moins de dix
ans le risque était plutôt diminué de
24%
on sait maintenant que l'estrogène
augmente la longévité et réduit le
risque de maladies cardiaques graves de
50%
l'étude doit y a aussi révélé que
l'hormonothérapie diminuait les risques
de cancer du côlon et de fractures liées
à l'ostéoporose
mais c'est passé sous le radar c'est
quand tu penses que une femme sur quatre
vont refaire une fracture de hanche 28%
dans des segments annexe i certains taux
de mortalité de 7% en appel peau
depuis l'étude ouailles la consommation
d'hormones a chuté de 45% au québec
clame l'étude roya fait beaucoup de mal
alors une thérapie la docteure se fit de
zend terminé sa spécialité en
obstétrique et gynécologie
quand les résultats de l'étude ont été
publiés ça a été
vraiment ingrat direct heureusement pour
les femmes ménopausées vraiment là
[Musique]
saviez vous qu'il ya vingt et un ans
presque la moitié des femmes prenaient
des hormones et qu'aujourd'hui c'est
autour de 5% qu'est ce qui explique sa
probablement un excès de prudence
beaucoup d'ignorance mais ça cause
beaucoup de souffrance
[Musique]
j'ai écouté l'auto meinau et je me suis
mise à pleurer j'ai 44 ans encore
menstruée à tous les mois mais une tonne
de symptômes ont prescrit des
antidépresseurs depuis quatre ans mais
je ne suis pas dépressif
manon bono et l'administratrice d'un
groupe facebook où les femmes se
confient sur leur ménopause suite à
l'auto mais nos bas évidemment ça a
explosé la plainte qui revient le plus
souvent c'est la difficulté d'avoir des
hormones mon médecin m'a prescrit un
verre de vin que c'était pour passer
petit croissant à 2021 je suis à la
recherche d'un nouveau médecin j'entends
le la rage les femmes qui sont tannés
qui se disent et finissent par se
trouver un médecin au privé mais doivent
attendre des mois moi je reçois
abominable vingt ans après l'étude
ouailles malgré les réanalyse rassurante
la peur et la confusion persiste et
causent beaucoup de souffrance
des insomnies de l'anxiété de la déprime
de la fatigue des douleurs articulaires
libido à plat on parler de sécheresse
mais aussi toute assez chic des douleurs
musculo squelettiques très intense des
attaques de panique insomnies les cartes
de mémoire problèmes de mémoire des
problèmes de mémoire ces femmes du
groupe nous ont raconté comment les
symptômes de leur ménopause ou
périménopause n'ont pas été reconnus et
traités pendant des années ah je vais
aller voir au moins trois médecins
différents qui ne montraient pas fait
tous les matchs aller voir un premier
médecin m'a prescrit des anxiolytiques
et des somnifères et des tests on est
toujours négative pour l'or augmenté les
doses reçues aux antidépresseurs
gymnastique troubles de l'adaptation
troubles des sites de la patiente
dépression sévère fibromyalgie toutes
ces femmes voulaient prendre des
hormones mais se sont butés à la
résistance de leur médecin indien a dit
moi ça m'intéresse pas occupé de aucune
considération je m'en occupe et j'admire
par les mots l'endocrinologue qui lui me
disait non savoir de façon les armes ces
dangers m'a dit si vous voulez prendre
des hormones ça soit votre choix
c'est pas moi qui va vous le conseillez
les hormones le on peut attraper le
cancer avec ce
adam carroll mc oui les femmes qu'elles
me voir sont en colère parce qu'elles
veulent emprunter on leur refuse encore
aujourd'hui oui encore aujourd'hui en
2005 la docteur sylvie demers a fondé
une clinique privée pour se consacrer au
traitement de la ménopause trois ans
plus tard elle a écrit hormonaux
féminins et depuis elle est débordée
vous pouvez en effet
c'est sur une base quotidienne où
j'entends les femmes qui me supplient de
les prendre
il semble vraiment y avoir une pénurie
de médecins intéressés et qualifiés
un dommage collatéral de l'étude
ouailles il ya besoin de génération en
guinée l'un des deux médecins qui ont
arrêté de prescrire et bien c'est soit
que ça se répercute sur les résidents
conforme parce qu' une partie de leur
formation c'est qu'on les supervise un
clinic donc si on leur manque pas
comment prescrire je pense que ça a eu
un impact
[Musique]
non j'ai commencé alors le site fait
prescrire l'hormonothérapie
féminine avec art et sciences docteur
demers donne régulièrement des
formations à des médecins dans le but de
remettre les pendules à l'heure les
objectifs de la journée ce matin on va
reparler plus des avantages de
l'hormonothérapie film une vie
authentique comparativement à celles non
bio identique
[Musique]
sylvie demers ne prescrit que des
hormones bio identique une hormone est
dit bio identique lorsque sa structure
chimique est identique à celle d hormone
fabriquée naturellement par les femmes
généralement les femmes prennent deux
hormones de la progestérone et de
l'estrogène il y à la progestérone bio
identique et eliane progestine non bio
identique qu'on appelle l'as étape 2 mai
drogue si progestérone du côté des
estrogènes il y as l'estradiol bio
identiques qui peut être pris par voie
orale ou par voie transdermique via un
timbre ou au gel et il y a les
estrogènes conjugués et qu'un fait à
partir du rin de jument vous trouvez que
c'est compliqué vous n'êtes pas les
seuls
le gros problème qu'on en
hormonothérapie y en eu plusieurs là
mais le plus gros c'est qu'on ne
distingue pas les différentes center
monothérapie c'est la société des
obstétriciens et gynécologues du canada
la sgc qui dicte les règles que suivent
les médecins en matière de traitement de
la ménopause
une mise à jour des directives cliniques
de la sgc vient d'être publié skela plus
dérangeant c'est les contre indications
ça vient beaucoup dérangé
selon la hes-so gc une femme ne doit pas
prendre d'hormones si elle a des
antécédents de cancer du sein d'avc et
de thromboembolie de caillots sanguins
alors que l'hormonothérapie bio d'un tic
a rien prouvé de ça
les contre indications ne font pas la
différence entre les hormones bio
identique et les non bio identique une
aberration selon docteur demers surtout
en ce qui concerne la progestérone et sa
cousine non bio identique la mp moi ça
fait longtemps que je dis que là à
l'anpe ou l'acétate de médréac si
progestérone devrait banide en
monothérapie ou du moins réservé à des
cas extrêmes ne s'est pas des femmes
t'as l'air pour la progestérone parce
que c'est le responsable de
l'augmentation des codes sens au sein de
la capture d'une you came c'est très
près documenté docteur sophie de zend a
déjà participé à la rédaction des
directives cliniques et de la mjc au
niveau des contre indications
vous ne faites pas la différence par
exemple entre les progestine et la
progestérone pourquoi vous faites
possède différents cela en fait souvent
ses prix en termes de classe parce qu'on
n'a pas des études d'aussi bonne qualité
sur tous les produits les hormones bio
identique n'ont jamais fait l'objet
d'une étude de niveau 1 une grande étude
clinique contrôlé comme l'étude ouailles
les contre indications sont donc basée
entre autres sur l'étude ouailles même
si elle n'a évalué que les hormones non
bio identique
malheureusement on n'a pas bien belle
choix d'extrapoler ces données-là à la
grande place des projets saint jean n b
yen est ce qu on entend beaucoup cité
troyenne qui arrive à la conclusion que
la combinaison d'oestrogène et de
progestérone
contrairement aux autres progestine
n'augmente pas les russes de kazan 5 à 8
ans de suivi y avait pas d'augmentation
moi ce que je peux dire aujourd'hui
c'est on a une grande étude qui démontre
jusqu'à 8 ans n'y a pas d'augmentation
quand sable c'est pourquoi c'est pas dit
dans les lignes directrices on a eu une
itt sud
une étude de niveau 2 se passer ses
limites
pour ce qui est des risques de caillots
sanguins l'autre grande peur liée aux
hormones les contre-indications met
encore une fois dans le même panier deux
produits différents
l'estradiol pris par voie orale qui
augmente le risque de caillot et
l'estradiol transdermique on n'a pas de
démontrer scientifiquement que
l'estradiol cette beta transdermique
augmentait le risque de thrombose
veineuse et on fait comme si pourquoi on
met tous les oestrogènes dans le même
paquet d'un même bateau il ya des études
de niveau 2 encore une fois qu'ils ont
démontré qu'ils avaient pas
d'augmentation du risque de thrombose
mais c'est des études de niveau 2 on le
pose cette étude là qui nous rassure à
100% sur le risque de thrombose on se
demande un petit peu si l'excès de
prudence des des sociétés savantes
n'entretient pas un peu la confusion et
la difficulté d'accès aux hormones pour
beaucoup de femmes
c'est vrai que
qui ont un excès de prudence
shu je suis d'accord qui ont un certain
excès de prudence dans le fond ce qui
est une erreur c'est de considérer que
toutes les contre indications cédé
contre indication absolue
au lieu de demander aux médecins qui
manque de formation de prendre des
libertés avec les directives des
sociétés savantes docteur demers suggère
de les changer tant qu'on changera pas
les recommandations
on va rester bloqué on va rester sur un
mode confusionnel où on va tout mélanger
quatre des six femmes qui nous avons
parlé ont obtenu les hormones dont elle
avait besoin en consultant des médecins
qui pratiquent en privé c'est là que
j'ai commencé à retrouver mes moyens
je sentais que tous mes symptômes
étaient contrôlés c'est vraiment il ya
l'amélioration physique puis la douleur
l'énergie sur l'énergie se
retrouver la joie de vivre trouver une
confiance en moi le corps qui qui qui
renaît
nathalie et marie hélène quant à elles
sont toujours seuls avec leurs symptômes
l'autre frein pour l'accès aux hormones
c'est l'argent pour le moment la ramq ne
rembourse pas les hormones qui sont les
plus sécuritaires les bio identique mais
qui sont aussi les plus chers mais
est-ce qu'on a calculé combien ça vaut
la qualité de vie des femmes
moi j'ai un historique d'enfants sur
deux générations deux camps satisfaisant
mère et ma grand-mère ont eu des grains
marie-hélène bourbeau a toujours été
convaincus qu'elle ne pouvait pas
prendre d'hormones à
l'otan c'est une phrase qui a été
répétée et les hormones par pitié tout
jamais à ça c'est en regardant l'auto
meinau qu'elle découvre que son
historique familial n'est pas une
contre-indication à l'hormonothérapie ve
jeter franchise afin de défendre parce
que je me disais comment ça se fait que
je savais pas nathalie deschênes elle
n'a pas obtenu d'hormones parce que ça
médecins étaient d'avis qu'on ne doit
pas en prescrire pendant la
périménopause
devrait
aider
les deux femmes étaient désespérés
lorsque nous les avons rencontrés sur
une liste de médecins qui ont suivi la
formation de docteur demers nous en
avons trouvé deux qui ont accepté de les
recevoir
nous y reviendrons
je viens courir ici très souvent dans le
parc de gatineau partie d'une chaîne de
vie de venir ici dans la nature dans le
bois docteur demers est une coureuse de
fond sa croisade pour que les hormones
bio identique soit reconnu comme étant
sécuritaires dure depuis 17 ans moi ça
me prend beaucoup pour m'écraser en fait
carton m'écrase c'est comme un défi
relevé je suis un personne des défis son
défi c'est de convaincre la régie de
l'assurance maladie du québec d'assurer
une couverture universelle de la
progestérone bio identique et de
l'estradiol transdermique depuis
toujours parce qu'elle coûte plus cher
ces hormones sont remboursés uniquement
aux patients qui présentent des
conditions particulières les autres
doivent les payer de leur poche environ
80 dollars par mois c'est un irritant
majeur parce que beaucoup de femmes
beaucoup médecins viennent à
l'information ils me disent benjamas à
les prescrire mais je travaille auprès
d'une clientèle défavorisée et ont pas
les moyens de ses prescrire à partir de
chiffres fournis par la ramq eu nous
avons estimé que la couverture
universelle des bio identique pourrait
faire passer le coût annuel de
l'hormonothérapie de 14 à 24 millions de
dollars
quand on regarde ça d'un point de vue
sociétal
quand on a une efficacité similaire des
y'a pas de raison payer plus cher pour
avoir accès à une eau terek
dans l'auto meinau sylvie bouchard de
l'inesss l'institut national
d'excellence en santé et en services
sociaux
explique que la balle est dans le camp
des fabricants de bio identique que la
ramq paiera lorsqu'ils auront prouvé
avec des études cliniques de niveau 1
que le meilleur profil d'innocuité leurs
produits justifient leur prix plus
élevés pour rassembler toutes ses
preuves lors le choix le plus simple
c'est définitivement par le magnifique
sonic commercialise ses produits
le problème c'est que l'étude clinique
qu'attend l'inesss les manufacturiers ne
la feront jamais quand un médicament
comme le promet trium devient génériques
et que du jour au lendemain on se
retrouve avec cinq compagnies qu'il
fabrique personne ne va faire de
nouvelles études cliniques qui sont
extrêmement coûteuses
alain boisvert et directeur des
relations gouvernementales chez
pharmascience une des compagnies qui
fabriquent un générique du promet trium
la première progestérone bio identique
qui a été commercialisé de raisonnement
de l'ina et c'est bon quand ça clique
des mets des fabricants novateur qui ont
un brevet qui leur permet d'avoir un
prix plus élevé il mesurait de
commercialisation exclusive
mais enlever ce puits élevé et enlever
la belle exclusivité le fabricant qui
investiraient dans un essai clinique le
ferait essentiellement à perte et
probablement au bénéfice de ses
concurrents on aurait davantage intérêt
dans le code inez conçu un groupe
d'experts qui pourrait conseiller line
un sommet le meilleur statut
remboursement de ce médicament
lorsqu'on analyse les habitudes de
prescriptions des médecins on dirait
qu'ils ont déjà tranché en faveur des
bio identique en croisant des chiffres
fournis par la ramq cul et parly cuvée
ya une compagnie d' analyse de données
nous avons estimé que quand les femmes
sont assurés par la ramq eu les médecins
leur prescrivent de l'estradiol
transdermique dans 19 % des cas
lorsqu'elles ont une assurance privée ça
monte à 36 % dans le cas de la
progestérone bio identique ces 23 % des
prescriptions quand c'est la ramq qui
paie contre 73% quand c'est le privé
nous asseoir privé bon peut-être
favorisé certaines thérapies qui vont
mettre en évidence la qualité de vie des
patients alors que nous on fait des
recommandations dans un système de santé
dont on veut au frais je dirais la base
depuis le tome i know l'inesss a reçu de
nouvelles demandes d'évaluation de
manufacturiers de bio identique les
documents que nous avons obtenus
démontrent encore une fois l'inesss met
la barre très haut ce que vous demandez
leur ce sont des essais cliniques qui
soutiennent que les avantages des
hormones bio identique par rapport aux
hormones synthétiques existent sont des
données comme soyez en europe alors le
fabricant peut soumettre un argumentaire
qui doit être basée sur des données en
contexte réel de soins on est toujours
disponible à pouvoir trouver une voie de
passage on comprend qu'il ya donc un
ange deux actuellement actuellement ce
sont les femmes qui paient le prix de la
difficulté d'accès aux hormones tu en as
maladie accumulés au cours des
mois je suis à mon troisième arrêt de
travail il ya cinq ans d'arrêt de
maladie qui est rattachée à toute la
série de symptômes condamner tout à
l'heure les choses seraient sur le point
de s'améliorer on en parle
l'auto mais noah encore plus ouvert la
porte ici au québec je pense que c'est
c'est très important qu'on en parle
docteur jeanne bhutto vient de terminer
sa sueur spécialisation en traitement de
la ménopause
elle constate que le regain d'intérêt
des femmes pour les hormones se traduit
par une demande accrue de formation -
quasiment toutes mes clinique j'ai
toujours des apprenants avec moi ça peut
être des étudiants en médecine des
résidents des étudiants sont toujours
très intéressés et qu'est-ce que docteur
bhutto enseigne aux médecins et futurs
médecins on parle que la progestérone et
probablement plus sécuritaire au niveau
du sens que les progestatifs synthétique
pour les oestrogènes je vous dirais que
c'est un petit peu plus mitigé
actuellement on a quand même des données
qui semblent montrer que la voie
transdermique et supérieur et moins
risqué que la voie orale mais encore une
fois je pense jamais un portrait qui est
toujours il faut que tout le monde
prenne ça où il faut que tout le monde
prenne ça je pense que toutes les
options devraient être disponibles sans
que le facteur financier viennent jouer
le virage qui semble s'amorcer pourrait
bien changer la vie de milliers de
femmes j'ai mes prescriptions
vraiment des prescriptions de presse
bassin des prescriptions pour les deux
hormones pour pour débuter le traitement
marie hélène a obtenu un bon service
dans une clinique publique nathalie
quant à elle a été prise en charge par
la clinique privée de la docteure ligne
des hôtels dont nathalie est ce que ce
matin oui ça lui alors que quand je
regarde les dosages hormonaux ton niveau
d'estradiol est à
651,7 651 c'est acceptable la
progestérone elle est seulement à 6
points 4 ça devrait être à peu près
entre 40 et st
alors on va prescrire de la progestérone
nathalie a dû débourser
450 dollars
mais elle estime que ça valait le coup
cette rencontre m'a permis de revoir des
espoirs je souhaitais pas juste le matin
ça me permet à moi
de pouvoir me dis ouf quelques groupes
sont sous l'eau
pour la docteure demers aussi de grands
changements se préparent je vais aborder
le sujet tout de suite mais vous avez
sûrement entendu parler que je fais mes
lacunes dans la rue
docteur demers ferme s'incliner pour se
consacrer à la formation et à l'écriture
d'articles scientifiques
elle a aussi lancé une pétition qui
demande que toutes les hormones soit
universellement couverte j'ai toujours
pensé que les révolutions next up et
dans l'eure monothérapie je pense que ça
va venir des femmes des infirmières et
des médecins famille m'attend pokes à
vienne des sociétés savantes souvent du
fait que ces groupes une force d'inertie
docteur demers va continuer de se battre
tant que la peur de l'hormonothérapie
n'aura pas disparu
garantie que les taux sauvé énormément
d'argent on aurait des femmes
vieillissant bien plus en forme profit
profiterait de la revue des meilleurs
citoyenne plus engagé moi je pense que
c'est une grande question santé publique
[Musique]